sans surprise plusieurs préfèrent
qu'elle soit abolie quelques minutes
dollars de moins à payer quand on achète
une première maison ce serait le
bienvenu peut-être la première propriété
de la volée pour ce monde est vraiment
changé la terminologie et a du coup en
réduire le coût la taxe de bienvenue ce
sont les droits de mutation immobilière
perçue par les villes ils doivent être
payés quand une maison change de
propriétaire ils vont mettre 5 % de mise
à fond mais 5% d'une maison dont 500000
ces 26es mêlée par dessus votre loi qui
rajoute ainsi cette ville de taxe de
bienvenue ça peut être l'autre un
premier ashton la chef du parti libéral
promet de l'abolir pour permettre aux
premiers acquéreurs de souffler un peu
et de compenser les villes
cent-pour-cent a compensé par le
gouvernement libéral sans
la mairesse de montréal répond on ne
peut absolument pas malheureusement se
priver de ses sources de financement car
ces droits de mutation sont une source
de revenus importante entre 800 et 900
millions $ annuellement pour les
municipalités selon lui m q qui lance
elle aussi une mise en garde toute
brèche dans ses revenus se traduira
nécessairement par un transfert fiscal
vers d'autres contribuables comme les
résidents ou encore les propriétaires de
commerces les courtiers immobiliers
appuyé l'idée avec réserve ou un
situations d'urgence et haut la main en
mesure musique est une bonne mesure leur
association estime qu'il faut d'abord
améliorer l'offre donc augmenter le
nombre de propriétés disponibles ce qui
aura pour effet d'équilibrer le marché
manque de propriété sur le marché pour
améliorer l'offre donc on peut penser à
des solutions comme le logement social
et abordable des subventions des
meilleures conditions aux que les peaux
mates en recul le retard du nombre de
chantiers l'idée de mettre au rancart la
taxe de bienvenue ne date pas d'hier
mais ce n'est qu'une des nombreuses
pistes de solutions pour améliorer
l'accès à la propriété il sait mélissa
françois radio canada montréal